-Thank you for even letting me
go near this championship belt.
This is the real deal.
Look at this, man.
This is gorgeous. Holy moly!
I got to say, not only are you
a WWE Superstar,
but you are one the best
to ever do it, buddy.
I mean, really amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Ever. Of all time.
I'm going to move this,
Yeah, if you don't mind if I
can -- Gosh, it's heavy.
-Easy. Take it easy.
-Alright, buddy, I will.
Trust me. Yeah, I will.
We were talking backstage,
and you made me laugh,
because I know you have kids.
You have two sets of
twins, right?
-I do, yeah.
-And they're babies, right?
How --
-Well, we have one set --
they're about a year and half,
and then the other set just
turned 5 on the 11th.
-Yeah. And then you also have a
teenager on top of that.
-Yeah, yeah.
She's about to turn 14.
Yeah, I know.
She's the handful right now.
-Yeah.
No, but I think you're a little
bit of a handful, too,
because we were talking --
-That's what she would say.
-Yeah, good.
See? I got her back.
Yeah, she goes --
I go, "Oh, my gosh, 14.
That's so cute."
And you go, "Yeah, I feel like
I embarrass her."
And I go,
"How do you embarrass her?"
And then --
You want to tell everyone
what you did
to your poor daughter?
-Well, she was explaining to me
that, like, right now,
the whole Christmas music
before Thanksgiving is, like,
a big thing.
They're trying to cancel
this whole situation
of Mariah Carey,
and that's just craziness to me.
-That's exactly right.
Play music --
Christmas music, yeah.
-Let's go, right?
-Let's go!
Right away.
Halloween's out of here.
Christmas music now.
-I love Mariah Carey.
I love Christmas music. Yeah.
-So, we're pulling up.
I'm dropping her off at school.
And it's, like,
a little circle, you know,
that you have to
drop them off at.
And as soon as we pull up
to this circle,
I just crank "All I Want for
Christmas is You," yeah.
And, you know, I turn it down to
tell her I love her
and goodbye,
and then,
as soon as she opens the door,
I just crank it up again.
Yeah, she melts.
And then, literally, there was
like five of her friends
turning the corner,
going to classes
that all witnesses
this whole situation.
She closes the door
as fast as he she can,
and then there's the second
where she -- "Oh, no."
She's got a project
in the back seat.
She has to re-open the door.
Yeah, so...
-And then you
cranked it up again.
I just love that, buddy.
-Yeah.
-Were you always a big kid?
Were you always, like --
Like, were you the kid
that got picked
for every team in gym class?
-I was that kid, yeah.
-You were?
-Yeah, yeah, I was that guy.
But, I mean, there was --
So, at an early age,
I was always the kid
that had to cut weight
to make the football team,
like, the weight limit
and everything.
So I'd literally be,
before a game,
running in a trash bag
around, like,
a baseball field,
just sweating it out --
-To lose weight.
-Yeah.
-To get to weight.
-There would be times where
I'd be in my underwear --
you know what I mean? --
in order to weigh in
and make the game.
And they'd have, like,
McDonald's waiting for me,
all kinds of just breakfast,
fast food, ready to go.
-Yeah.
-But then I hit, like --
Right before puberty,
probably like 7th grade,
8th grade,
the beginning of 8th grade,
I became the, like, small kid.
And my sisters --
they're are all 6-footers.
They're all --
-You were the small kid?
-Well, at this time,
I was, yeah.
So, for about
year and half, two years
in middle school,
it just didn't look like
it was going to happen for me.
Like, so --
-Weren't gonna sprout, yeah.
-My sisters were just kind of
ribbing me the whole time,
messing with me, you know,
talking smack to me
about how I'm going to be the
smallest in the family
and everything.
And then, thank God, finally,
we hit puberty
and, yeah, we started to
shoot up a little bit.
So it all worked out.
-It all worked out, yeah.
I got say, you have a bunch of
great signature moves,
but one of my favorites is
the Superman punch.
-Mm-hmm.
-This is -- Look at this here.
Just -- That's you.
That's you, by the way.
That's not fake or CGI or put --
You're flying, basically.
-I really did that, yeah.
-Yeah.
What -- My question is,
what are you seeing?
'Cause this is
what we're seeing.
But what are you seeing when
you see the opponent's face?
Like, what are they --
what are they doing?
Are they going like, "No,"
or what?
-"N-N-N-No." Yeah.
Bunch of stuttered nos.
Remorse, regret.
You know what I mean?
-Remorse.
-Final thoughts or prayers.
I don't know.
You know, it's like, "Why am I
in here with this guy?"
One of those things, yeah.
-This weekend, you're going --
This is a big match.
-Survivor Series, yeah.
-Survivor Series.
-Yeah, this Sunday,
Barclays Center,
it's going down.
-Survivor Series this Sunday.
And this is also, weirdly,
the 25th anniversary of
The Rock.
-You guys know that.
You know that guy, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-This is...
Survivor Series, 25 years,
The Rock, the rumors.
You don't have to say
"yes" or "no,"
but people are thinking maybe
he's going to make
an appearance.
-These are rumors,
you're saying.
-Well...is it?
I don't know if it's a rumor.
-I have not heard these rumors.
And I would think I'm closer
than anybody at this point.
So, I don't know.
It's not what I've heard.
But I also debuted at
Survivor Series, as well.
So there's a nice little
tie-in there.
-Yeah.
-But -- I don't know.
-But fans think that you guys --
I know you're
family and everything,
but they think you guys should
fight each other.
Would you ever fight The Rock?
-I would, yes.
I don't know if he wants it.
But -- So,
that's kind of something
that we do in our family
as far as,
you know, sports entertainment,
professional wrestling, WWE.
This is our platform.
This is our family business.
You know, I fought one of
my cousins, the Usos, Jey Uso,
you know, about a year ago.
And where better to
kind of solve problems
than in the squared circle,
you know?
-That's exactly right.
That's correct.
I know that --
I want to quickly mention,
last week, tickets went on sale
for WrestleMania 38 in Dallas.
-Yeah.
-Let me tell you something.
I've been to a WrestleMania.
WWE does not mess around.
These things are legit.
They are such a giant event.
And this is now a two-day event.
-Yeah, I mean, somehow, WWE --
We've managed to
make it even bigger.
So, yeah, it's like --
-I know, last year, Bad Bunny --
-Oh, yeah,
we had Bad Bunny come through.
It's always kind of a --
You know,
we try to bring as much
outside entertainment
and just make it
as big as possible.
So, I think...
I don't want to reach here,
but we got to have you.
-Me?
-Yeah! Why not?
-Really?
-Why not?
You guys want to see
Jimmy Fallon
at WrestleMania 38, right?
Not to put him on the spot here.
-I'm there.
-The invite's there.
-I will -- If you invite me,
I'm there.
-We shook on it.
-Of course.
-Business is done.
-I'm there.
This Sunday,
what can we expect from you?
-I'm gonna smash him.
Come on.
-Yeah. At this point, yeah.
-I will say, I'm going against
a really great athlete.
Big E -- he's the WWE champion.
He's the best on "Raw."
But, I mean,
my work is spoken for.
I'm operating at a
whole different level, man.
So we're going to smack
him around.
-That's exactly right.
-Yeah.
-You're the best, bud.
Thanks for coming by.
Please. And I'll see you at
WrestleMania.
-Yes, sir.
-Roman Reigns, everybody.
-Thank you, guys.
-Tickets are on sale for
WrestleMania 38.
You can see Roman in the
WWE Survivor Series,
which is streaming live on
Peacock this Sunday, 8:00 p.m.